[Musique]
audition publique
al'approche sinon à l'heure du
remaniement merci de nous rejoindre donc
comme chaque lundi pour ce nouveau
rendez-vous des chaînes parlementaires
de la sp et du figaro où nous sommes
installés et bonsoir madame nicole
belloubet et merci d'être avec nous dans
un premier temps avec yves thréard du
figaro
bonsoir christophe schmitt de l' agence
france presse ansa encore monsieur
madame la ministre ministre de la
justice vous êtes donc ministre de la
justice vous resterez je le souhaite
vous le souhaitez je le souhaite mais
comme vous le savez c'est à la
discrétion du premier ministre et du
président de la république cet instant
précis qu'elle est quelles sont les
éventuelles informations vous concernant
je n'en ai pas vous le saurez lorsque
l'annoncé du nouveau gouvernement sera
présenté
imaginons que vous soyez reconduite le
ministre de l'intérieur en revanche lui
bah il sera à nouveau
c'est probable vous souhaitez avoir une
relation une relation particulière entre
un mini zoo la justice est remise à
l'intérieur on sait qu'avec gérard
collomb
sap a toujours été très simple parce que
ils avaient tendance est bien à prendre
ses aises
allez un petit peu sur vos plats dedans
non je dirais pas ça non pas du tout ce
qu'on a constaté nous à huy jeu non non
non non vraiment pas je mens je
m'explique d'abord je vous dirais que
nous travaillons avec plusieurs
ministres surtout au ministère de la
justice parce que nous sommes le
ministère qui écrit la loi qui écrit le
droit est par exemple j'ai travaillé
avec jacques mézard sur le logement et
la copropriété j'ai travaillé que
marlène schiappa sur les violences j'ai
travaillé avec gérard collomb sur la
politique pénale
on a travaillé de manière extrêmement
intense puisque vous le savez il ya des
attentes très fortes
du côté des forces de police et de
gendarmerie sur la phase de l'enquète et
donc nous avons travaillé ensemble très
bien et quand il a fait le texte sur
contre le terrorisme sur justement
l'allée des réformes nécessaires lorsque
j'ai cessé lorsque j'ai des choses à
dire
préalablement à la loi sa présentation
devant le parlement
je les dis à l'intérieur du gouvernement
j'ai eu l'occasion de faire des
observations c'est tout à fait mon beau
damphousse est soucieuse quand même d'un
certain équilibre avec votre homologue
de la place beauvau c'est une question
effectivement le jour tant pour vous oui
mais bien sûr c'est que je suis
soucieuse de l'équilibré
et surtout je suis soucieuse de la
garantie des droits de la garantie de la
constitution des policiers souvent et
les gendarmes et puis on l'entend aussi
dans public c'est à dire que ils
arrêtent ils arrêtent des malfaiteurs et
puis il les retrouve une semaine trois
semaines après dans la rue parce que les
juges il estime que les juges bien ne
les ont pas n'ont pas fait leur travail
non mais je sais tout cela mais vous
savez aussi qu'il y à des postures qui
lie à des caricatures et donc moi mon
souci c'est vraiment et nous serons
peut-être l'occasion d'en parler tout à
l'heure de faciliter le travail de l'anc
est de le simplifier
mais également évidemment au moment de
la phase du jugement de protéger les
droits ce sens naturel best of
madame la ministre vous êtes pour
présenter deux ministères qui écrit la
loi ça tombe bien justement demain soir
si tout va bien pour vous vous
présenterez au sénat un projet de
réforme de la justice assez ambitieux
d'aucuns ont même parlé de fourre tout
des avocats prévoient de venir
manifester devant le sénat rejette assez
ambitieux et fourre tout ça veut dire la
même chose mais enfin mourad quand on
paye les vastes et des avocats prévoient
de venir manifester
devant le sénat la bâtonnière de paris
marie aimée perron critique très
durement votre projet ce matin dans le
parisien je la cite elle parle d'une
logique simplement budgétaire qui
éloigne le citoyen de la justice une
justice sans juge ni avocat ni citoyen
et elle prend un exemple qui peut qui
peut parler à beaucoup de gens c'est
celui de la révision des pensions
alimentaires qui serait dévolue aux
directeurs de café non plus aux juges
est ce que c'est vraiment des directeurs
de café mieux passé pour alors je
voudrais tout de même revenir sur les
propos que le cas retenus marie-aimée
paierons s'ils sont bien d'elle je crois
d'ailleurs
oui non mais je sais pas si cet autre
oui on s'y attendait prenons les choses
point par point une justice sans avocat
je trouve ça invraisemblable ni ne
touchons absolument pas à la présence
des avocats et même nous renforçons la
représentation obligatoire dans le texte
de loi que je propose une justice sans
juge ça n'est pas possible non plus
puisque tout notre processus et
l'augmentation des moyens évidemment y
conduit tout cela conduit à augmenter le
nombre de juges
en 2008 il y avait huit mille cent
soixante quatre juges en 2018
il y à 8400 juge en 2010 500 dont les
réformes et andy pas de juge pas
d'avocat tout cela est donc il exhale je
viens de vous le dire et pas de citoyen
je ne sais pas ce que cela veut dire
dans la mesure où ce que je porte vise à
renforcer la proximité avec les citoyens
donc je pense que ces termes sont
excessives si je respecte beaucoup marie
aimée perron et ce qu'elle représente
je trouve que la terminologie est un peu
excessive là pour parler de 2
de la procédure effectivement la
création du tribunal criminel
départemental pour les crimes passibles
de jusqu'à 20 ans de réclusion je crois
est critiqué par les avocats aussi parce
que considère que les droits des
victimes
être simplement entendu seront moins
respecté que dans un tribunal avec un
jury populaire
non moi si vous voulez je comprend au
regard de la proposition que nous
faisons je comprends que cette
proposition soit discutée par ce que il
est vrai que dans notre droit la cour
d'assises à je dirais une aura tout à
fait particulière au delà de son rôle
effectif mais ce que l'on constate
aujourd'hui c'est que pour passer devant
une cour d'assises il faut attendre
extrêmement longtemps pour plusieurs
raisons d'abord parce que la procédure
est effectivement longue puisque c'est
une procédure qui est uniquement orale
parce que également l'appel a été
instaurée donc cela rallonge les
procédures ce que nous proposons vise
exactement l'inversé de ce que disent un
certain nombre d'avocats c'est à dire ce
que nous cherchons c'est à donner
satisfaction plus rapidement et tout
aussi bien aux victimes comme aux
auteurs pour avoir un jugement plus
rapides et ils passeront jeu non je
tiens à m'excuser c'est important là
dessus je y passeront devant un tribunal
qui sera composée de cinq magistrats qui
sont des magistrats professionnels
au nom du peuple français mais que je
sache je crois pas de jury populaire
mais quand vous êtes devant un tribunal
correctionnel connell l'âge de l'accord
rendu à cette fois ci la cour de
cassation des crimes ce sont mes les
magistrats me semble-t-il sont habilités
à rendre la justice au nom du peuple
vous trouvez normal qu'aujourd'hui où le
viol est quelque chose qui est bien
qu'atteint cricket un crime mais qui
justement la conscience collective
commencent à prendre la mesure de ce que
c'est avec le mouvement mis tous et que
justement les viols qui sont passibles
de 20 ans d'emprisonnement
un peu moins de 20 ans et bien passe
devant un tribunal correctionnel un
tribunal départemental même si très à ce
que vous savez si vous regardez les
faits aujourd'hui c'est que les viols
qui sont décrits sont requalifiés par du
temps ils sont requalifiés ils sont
requalifiés pour être jugées plus
rapidement parce que les victimes en ont
besoin devant un tribunal correctionnel
ce que je propose c'est qu'on les juge
en tant que crime devant un tribunal
criminel départemental avec un appel qui
sera toujours possible devant la cour de
rester à ce moment là absolument alors
il ya quelque chose aussi qui est
intéressant parce que vous êtes ancien
membre du conseil constitutionnel
professeur émérite de droit de ged droit
non pas l'agrégé et la question est la
suivante le lien avec le parquet est-ce
que ce lien va subsister
puisque vous savez qu'il fait l'objet de
pas mal de critiques alors répond à
chaque fois des oppositions politiques
ou des journalistes
oui alors le lien avec le parquet dans
notre système français me semble devoir
subsister j'en donne une raison très
simple nous avons un article de notre
constitution l'article 20 qui précise
que le gouvernement détermine et conduit
la politique de la nation et donc il est
responsable devant le parlement de cette
politique
parmi cette politique conduite par le
gouvernement il y à la politique pénale
cette politique pénale elle est déclinée
par le garde des sceaux et par les
magistrats du parquet donc si vous
voulez il y a clairement sur les
politiques pénales qu'est ce que c'est
qu'une politique pénale c'est la lutte
contre les violences sexistes c'est la
lutte dans les quartiers de reconquête
républicaine sur ces sur le voilà alors
c'est ça que je voulais dire serre que
d'une paris à l'article 20 qui définit
une ligne d'autorité et d'autre part et
dans la même constitution nous avons la
garantie de l'indépendance des
magistrats y compris des parquetiers sur
les questions ce lien avec le parquet
n'avait pas envie de l'actionner
aujourd'hui parce que vous mentionnez
effectivement les violences oui il y à
une recrudescence des violences
gratuites dans notre pays des violences
homophobes également la venue chanson
qu'elle se marie vous l'avez actionner
les actionnaires
le relais du sentiment de laxisme que
ressentent et policiers est-ce que vous
actionnez véritablement ce lien
s'allumant je suis d'abord de deux
manières d'abord je leur écris et
ensuite je leur parle je leur écris par
des circulaires qui sont des circulaires
que je signe moi même ou qui sont signés
par an directeur des affaires
criminelles peu importe
et au mois de mars dernier j'ai fait une
circulaire général de politique générale
dans laquelle il était expressément
indiqué que l'une de mes premières
priorités c'était la lutte contre les
violences sexuelles et donc tout cela
clairement dit d'une part et d'autre
part je réunis régulièrement et
finalement le camp c'est quand martine
aubry 10 dans certaines tours par
exemple à lille mais on pourrait parler
de bien d'autres villes en france
nous ne sommes plus en république et là
vous avez envie d'agir peut-être plus
vigoureusement mais absolument oui nous
allons faire nous avons envie d'agir
plus vigoureusement et nous le faisons
avec évidemment le ministère de
l'intérieur avec les forces de police
on travaille main dans la main nous
avons mis en place des cellules locales
qui nous permettent de lutter contre les
réseaux de drogue ou de blanchiment
d'argent souvent d'ailleurs très liés et
donc nous avons mis en place des
cellules locales ou les forces justice
de police de parkhead d'autres mystères
également interviennent ensemble et
c'est en cela que les politiques pénales
doivent bien se situer sous la
responsabilité du gouvernement rest of
c'est un autre sujet madame la nive et
dit tout à l'heure que vous espériez
vous souhaiteriez conserver vos
fonctions dans le prochain gouvernement
est sans doute une des raisons pour ça
c'est que votre ministère est un de ceux
qui voit son budget augmenter mais ne
fasse la raison mais je le crains sont
significatives ont considéré que ce que
j'avais à dire que c'est une conséquence
de mon action et c'est surtout une
conséquence de la volonté du président
de la république c'est du concret en
retard
rodez on a deux fois moins que les
allemands 3 mois le parc de parquetier
christophe voulait poser une question je
ne sais pas non mais je suis prête à
répondre à cela et bien sûr j'ai les
études européennes je les connais pas
mais il faut regarder
il faut regarder à périmètre comparable
d'abord les chiffres que vous citez là
les derniers chiffres sont de 2016
or depuis 2016 nous avons en 2018 et en
2019 considérablement augmenté le budget
de la justice donc je pense que dans
deux ans ces chiffres là ne seront plus
les mêmes nous avons fait des
projections et nous savons cyr désormais
l'engagement à huy sur 2020
oui monsieur c'est à dire que donc le
chiffre aujourd'hui enfin ceux qui sont
connus ils sont têtes de 2016 c'est
qu'en gros l'allemagne dépenses par
habitant environ 120 euros pour ces
justice chaque année quand la france
dépensera espace en cinq ans oui mais
vous savez je ne veux pas apporter la
contradiction pour porter la
contradiction mais ce que je disais à
monsieur thréard il faut comparer les
choses qui sont comparables par exemple
ne sont pas prises en compte dans ces
études là l'ensemble des juges non
professionnels qui interviennent en
france les juges prud'homaux les
tribunaux de commerce tout ça ce sont
des gens qui jugent des contentieux et
qui ne sont pas intégrés dans ces études
l'argent de cyril freu ne compare pas
les mêmes les mêmes périmètres
disons que si je ne prétends pas qu'il y
à de la malhonnêteté dans ces études
loin de là elles sont remarquablement
conduite
ce que je dis c'est qu'il faudrait
pénétrer chacun des systèmes de chacun
des pays pour pouvoir vraiment faire des
études le clic comparé ces quelques 24 %
d'augmentation sur cinq ans qu'est-ce
que de votre point de vue ça sera
suffisant ou est-ce qu'il faudra
poursuivre l'effort après mais il faudra
forcément poursuivre l'effort ça c'est
très clair c'est très clair la justice a
besoin de moyens mais les moyens ne font
pas tous les moyens ne servent à rien
s'il ne s'accompagne pas d'une
transformation profonde manière d'alors
justement une question fondamentale
le président de la république pendant sa
campagne il a été répété dix toutes les
peines doivent fait exécuter
ça c'est une chose certaine toutes les
peines ne s'accompagne pas
d'emprisonnement
les peines de moins d'un an et surtout
les peines de moins de 6 mois peuvent
être assorties ou aménagés par des
peines alternatives qu'elles sont sept
peines alternatives at on les moyens
de les appliquer à la place de la prison
alors d'abord de manière plus que
symbolique
nous parlerons plus de peine alternative
mais nous parlerons de peine autonome il
y a d'une part ça veut dire quelque
chose ça veut dire que la référence ne
sera plus seulement la peine
d'emprisonnement
donc nous avons des peines par exemple
de travail d'intérêt général
extrêmement efficace pour un certain
nombre de gens qui ont commis des
infractions par exemple à la sécurité
routière où un jeune c'est bon donc des
peines de travail d'intérêt général
nous avons de la détention domicile hier
sous surveillance électronique
le bracelet pour faire court mais c'est
de la détention nous avons des peines de
stage nous avons des peines
d'hébergement extérieure
nous avons des peines de sursis
probatoire et c'est donc il ya toute une
gamme de peine et il y a bien sûr la
prison qui demeure une peine et qui
demeure une peine qui doit être
évidemment appliquée mais ce que nous
avons construit c'est vraiment de dire
il y à toute une série de peines qui
sont sûrement plus efficace que la
prison pour un certain nombre de délits
en fonction de la dangerosité du prévenu
en fonction de sa situation personnelle
et puis bien sûr dans un certain nombre
de cahiers à la prison mais quand la
prison est prononcée elle est effectuée
d'accord alors sur la prison il ya
également dans les rouages
pardon de revenir aux missions oui
donc l'ambition c'est de construire 7000
places ne rejette que vous entendez
masse et 7000 jusqu'à la fin du
quinquennat c'est ça non le président de
la république a dit que nous ne
construirions 15000 places de prison
nous construirons 15 ans de prison c'est
l'objectif je le réaffirme clairement
mais c'est quand il passe de prison je
suis pas de faire ça pour créer une
place de prison donc nous disons il y
aura sept mille places qui seront livrés
en 2022 et 8000 qui seront commencés
avant 2022 parce que commencer ça
signifie avoir acquis les terrains avoir
fait les études c'est extrêmement la
moitié sera réalisée d'ici à la fin du
calcaire absolument et l'autre moitié
sera commencer d'ici à la fin du
quinquennat en question le court madame
la professeure
vous connaissez le mur des cons alors le
mur des cons c'était un mur qui a été
établi par le syndicat de la
magistrature réputé à gauche et qui
mettait tous ses ennemis idéologiques
sur un mur et il ya un procès qui va
s'ouvrir prochainement puisqu'il ya des
hommes et des femmes politiques qui ont
porté plainte
est-ce qu'on peut être magistrat avoir
des opinions politiques qu'on affiche et
rendre la justice équitablement un
magistrat est un citoyen comme un autre
et donc il doit avoir
il peut avoir des opinions politiques
c'est un devoir éthique
lorsque l'on rend la justice un devoir
déontologique évidemment de ne pas en
faire part je pense qu'il faut dissocier
les deux choses cette règle là est
d'ailleurs applicable à bien d'autres
professions et vous avez-vous condamné
le syndicat de la magistrature dans ses
compensations précédent il ne
m'appartient pas de le faire comme vous
le dites il ne m'appartient pas de
baulers comme vous le dites il y à une
instance qui est en cours
donc la justice tranchera juste un mot
quand on parle du du remaniement ces
derniers jours il le formule qui a fait
mouche il hier c'était celle de richard
ferrand qui a parlé de nouveau souffle
est ce que cette formule de nouveau
souffle peut s'incarner dans dans le
domaine ministériel
est-ce que ça a un sens à nouveau
souffle pour la justice ou est-ce qu'il
faut juste continuer comme on fait parce
que c'est un nouveau défi
j'apprécie beaucoup richard ferrand il a
le sens des mots et je trouve que tout
cela est très juste je vous dis non non
c'est vrai c'est vrai mais je dirais
plus que nouveau souffle il me semble
que ce dans quoi nous sommes engagés
c'est plutôt une course d'endurance et
que dans une course d'endurance
il faut savoir sauter les obstacles qui
sont nombreux qui se présente à nous il
faut savoir garder un rythme et je crois
que c'est plutôt dans cette course
d'endurance que nous sommes engagés donc
c'est pas vraiment un nouveau souffle
pour moi c'est plutôt une course
d'endurance qui dont il faut savoir
garder le rythme et quand vous parlez de
la justice le projet de loi que je vais
présenter à partir de demain
c'est un projet de loi qui que nous
avons travaillé depuis un an environ
et donc si vous voulez je n'ai pas
l'impression que c'est un nouveau départ
j'ai l'impression que je suis dans cette
transformation longues et sur laquelle
il faut être persévérant
mais quand vous dites endurance
justement on entend persévérance face au
mécontentement des français à
l'impatience a écouté la persévérance
suppose aussi de savoir gérer ses forces
et donc ça veut dire évidemment de
savoir prendre conscience de ce qu'il ya
autour du contexte elles sont des mois
je crois que le sommet des nouveaux
implants ce combat il m'avait mis à voir
aujourd'hui lorsqu'on a une ligne
le présidente que le président de la
république a fixés qui est autour de la
du triptyque libéré protéger unir cette
ligne là une fois que nous ayons les
forces pour la conduire à son terme ce
qui ne veut pas dire ne pas entendre ce
qui se passait tout accord merci
beaucoup merci monsieur merci nous vous
livrons puisque selon le schéma de
l'émission maintenant nous accueillons
deux parlementaires
font la rentrée donc dans ce studio
françois noël buffet bonsoir vous êtes
sénateur les républicains du rhône et co
rapporteur du projet qui nous occupe
aujourd'hui à vos côtés une go d'hernani
6 bonsoir vous êtes député la france
insoumises du nord et bouillonnant vous
vous étiez dans une prison ce week-end à
nîmes exactement la maison d'arrêt de
2000 qui a la caractéristique d'être la
maison d'arrêt avec la plus forte
surpopulation carcérale de la france
métropolitaine
quasiment 200 % donc je suis allé
constater ça sur place j'ai envie de
dire que la ministre a raison de vouloir
construire d'autres alors eh bien
écoutez nous on va avoir un point de
désaccord là dessus elle elle le sait
par avance mais clairement nous nous
pensons qu'il faut effectivement
désemplir les prisons et il faut une
déflation pénale dans son ensemble ce
n'est pas pour la politique qui est
poursuivi par ce texte puisque
effectivement on construit 7000 places
de prison supplémentaires et même 15
milles au delà de 2022 mais j'espère que
d'ici là on changera de majorité dans le
pays
j'y compte bien clairement je pense que
vous avez raison madame la ministre
quand vous dites que les moyens
suffisent pas ce pas là la seule
question et c'est le sens de ce qu'on
fait vous avez dit que c'est le sens de
l'âme de notre manière de travailler
c'est pas que le sens de notre manière
de travailler mais c'est bien le sens de
la justice et de la peine et c'était ça
d'ailleurs l'intitulé de votre chantier
sur la peine et nous nous pensons que
pour redonner du sens à la peine il faut
qu'on crée le triptyque qui est voulu
par beaucoup de professionnels à savoir
l'amant de la peine d'amendé
la peine de probation autonome je dis
bien peine de probation autonome puisque
vous supprimez la contrainte pénale ce
qui va à l'opposé de ça et la peine de
prison qui doit être dans notre esprit
l'exception et non pas et non pas
l'annoncé d'ailleurs les côtes et
peut-être la réponse est oui alors
d'abord je connais la prison à la maison
d'arrêt de nîmes puisque je suis
également allé cet été
au moment où il ya eu une agression
grave d'un surveillant et donc je sais
évidemment que c'est une prison qui est
surpeuplée et c'est la raison pour
laquelle car il y a un besoin en termes
de politique pénale nous avons
évidemment des projections et nous
savons quelle sera l'évolution de la
population pénale
c'est donc la raison pour laquelle à
nîmes nous nous sommes engagés à mettre
en place un accroissement de capacité
d'accueil d'un certain nombre de place
pour soulager la maison d'arrêt d'osny
cela étant moi je ne souhaite pas
construire des places de prison pour les
remplir et c'est l'art qui avait c'est
la raison nous c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous avons redéfini une
politique pénale qui vous le savez
monsieur le député vise à mieux adapter
les peines à la réalité des infractions
et des personnes qui ont commis ces
infractions et donc à dire que la peine
de prison doit être une peine utile et
donc pour que ce soit une peine utile
nous disons que à côté de la peine de
prison pardonnez moi je me répète juste
un instant plus tard d'autres peines qui
seront alors vous avez raison on parlait
de l'amande
elle existe depuis longtemps mais il y a
effectivement des peines de travail
d'intérêt général de détention
domiciliaire sous bracelet électronique
des peines de
bref toute une gamme du relais et donc
d'une certaine manière notre si vous
voulez notre ambition on donne autonome
et sont deux provinces seront automne en
donner la peine que je propose pas le
dira le travail d'intérêt général par
exemple seront autonomes
le sursis pour toi quels moyens pardon
dites-moi par quels moyens ils seront
tous non parce que tout simplement dans
le code pénal elles seront conçues comme
des peines autonome et non plus comme
des peines en référence à la peine de
prison
enfin mme buffet peut-être d'abord un
mot sur les prisons parce que vous vous
avez également un point de vue qui n'est
pas tout à fait celui qu'on a entendu
pas tout à fait alors les un texte très
protéiforme à nous le savons un aspect
civile qui est très important et puis un
aspect naturellement qu'il est
tout autant avec quelques difficultés
alors sur le plan des maisons d'arrêt
des places de prison
oui nous sommes favorables à la
construction de 15000 places de prison
certes nous sommes favorables à tenir la
parole du président de la république qui
l'a prise avant d'être candidat aussi
sur les peines alternatives plus j'y
arrive nous serons nous souhaitons
vraiment dit vous les mains et ont
simplement que ses peines de ses places
de prison soit construite le plus
rapidement possible et nous pensons
qu'aujourd'hui ça n'est plus
l'engagement du présent qui est tenu
c'est une difficulté parce que la
surpopulation carcérale c'est une
réalité
marc roman sur échelle des peines si je
veux terminer ma mlle nice sur l'échelle
des peines
il ya un travail à faire qui n'est pas
fait dans ce texte en revanche on a
essayé d'essayer d'améliorer les choses
notamment
il faut dire les choses comme elles sont
en faisant de l'approbation une peine
principale c'est un exemple le sénat l'a
fait par voie d'amendement la semaine
dernière pour ne rien vous cacher parce
que nous pensons qu'il faut donner au
tribunal correctionnel tous les outils
possibles pour prendre la peine la plus
adaptée et surtout en réalité la plus
efficace
celle qui permettra à celui qui est
condamné de l'exécuter rapidement
efficacement de façon à ce que cela ait
du sens toute la difficulté aujourd'hui
c'est que toutes les peines
d'emprisonnement notamment inférieure ou
égale à deux ans il faut à peu près de
18 mois pour qu'elle soit exécutée et
c'est de ça qu'il faut sortir
je partage un certain nombre d' analyse
présentée par monsieur le sénateur
buffet à la fois pour dire que ce que
nous avons proposé ce que je propose
c'est un texte équilibré qui vise à la
fois à la construction d'établissements
pénitentiaires et entendez moi monsieur
le sénateur ne dit pas qu'on ne
construit que 7000 places de prison
alors que vous savez fort bien on en
construit 15000 mais vous savez très
bien qu'on ne peut pas construire quinze
mille places de prison en quatre ans ça
n'est pas possible vous le savez très
bien il faut je dois absolument du temps
et donc c'est la raison pour laquelle
les 7000 à l'horizon de 2020
non non vous avez tort vous avez tort
nous avons une réflexion à avoir autres
quel type de président de répondre à
monsieur le sénateur buffet donc c'est
un texte équilibré à la fois de
construction mais en même temps de
rénovation des peines
alors il ya nous sommes d'accord sur la
philosophie c'est à dire sur l'idée que
le tribunal correctionnel doit savoir
parce qu'il doit connaître la personne
qu'il a en face de lui il doit mieux
être en situation prononcer la peine
c'est la raison pour laquelle je crée
1500 postes de conseillers d'insertion
et de probation qui vont faire des
enquêtes de personnalité
l'association va permettre à fait que ce
qui alors nous pouvons être assez
d'accord réalité sur les objectifs
poursuivis en revanche moins peut-être
sur les moyens c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous avons une vision
différente sur le budget et nous pensons
que l'effort doit être non pas être de 4
% tel qu'il est prévu chaque année mais
2,5 pourquoi parce que si l'on veut que
le tribunal correctionnel dispose au
moment de l'audience des éléments
suffisants sur la personnalité de celui
qui va compagnie de celle qui va
comparaître
encore faut-il qu'ils aient tous les
éléments pour cela et donc que les
associations ou les services de
probation qui sont mandatées est le
temps là que le nom mais soit
suffisamment nombreux pour pouvoir faire
ça c'est extrêmement important en
matière de prononcer de peine et de bien
je veux bien monsieur le sénateur que
l'on accroissent le budget mais vous
n'êtes pas sans savoir
vous n'êtes pas sans savoir que nous
sommes dans le cadre d'un but que nous
sommes dans un gouvernement qui a
construit un budget contraint je suis
solidaire de ce gouvernement et je
considère que l'effort que nous faisons
qui est de plus d'un millier
six en cinq ans un milliard si cet
effort là est tout à fait considérable
et permet de pallier les difficultés que
nous avons rencontrées et cet effort là
je termine juste en ce moment là cet
effort là va nous permettre de donner
les moyens aux associations dont vous
parlez de nous aider à faire ce bilan
pré sentenciel de la personnalité des
condamnés enfin des futurs condamnés et
de recruter ou par des futurs condamnés
ou pas et va nous donner également la
possibilité de recruter ces fameux
conseillers d'insertion et de son
patient nous avons fait sur le plan
pénal et sur le plan des chèques des
peines notamment
il ya un travail à faire il est parfait
dans ce texte il faut remettre sur le
métier
il a en partie fait il a amélioré par le
sénat mais il faut reprendre tout
l'échelle dès peines est tout le quantum
des peines je pense que nous avons
vraiment besoin c'est un maquis
juridique c'est très compliqué pour nos
magistrats c'est pas compréhensible pour
les concitoyens encore parfois mois
prévu cette situation de lisibilité pour
les infractions les plus graves
c'est ce que nouvel objectif est ce que
c'est que la sanction qui sera prononcée
soit comprise et exécutés pour qu'elle
soit effective et que le système
fonctionne c'est ça la vie si vous savez
très bien juste là dessus vous savez
très bien aussi le sénateur que ce que
nous voulons précisément c'est rendre
les peines effective et vous le savez
alors qu'aujourd'hui une peine de prison
inférieures à deux ans peut être
aménagée dans le projet que je propose
j'assume le fait qu'une peine de prison
qui sera supérieure à un an devra
absolument être dans le fait que nous
avons modifié que nous verrons demain
sur les peines inférieures à un an nous
avons donné au juge tout l'outillage
possible qu'ils aient compris d'ailleurs
nous verrons dans les différents
positionnements du
gouvernement et vous même madame la
ministre sur la question de
l'approbation quand même plein autonome
en attendant dans votre texte vous
supprimez la contrainte pénale qui était
la seule personne contre elles ne
fonctionnent pas monsieur la corsa plus
sauf que là c'était pénale ne fonctionne
pas j'ai toujours ce qu'il a dû tout non
pas du tout il ya eu 2000 contraintes
canal qui sont prononcés ça ne me gêne
pas parce qu'on allait faire fonctionner
mais bien sûr mais c'est une tient pas
que la mesure ne fonctionne pas en
panneaux mais elle nous met son ampleur
et dans le sahel n'est pas ce qui est
énoncé l'état pendant ces jeux les donc
ça on ne peut pas le nier
et c'est la raison pour laquelle nous
avons construit cette peine de sursis
probatoire qui reprend les éléments
positifs du dossier les preuves et qui
au printemps il ya bien un horizon
civile en avance parce qu'on peut pas il
ya tellement de sujets alors elle ne
fonctionnait toujours proche du sursis
mise à l'épreuve
donc il faut absolument repenser le
système d'accord ce qu'une partie du
texte fait c'est ce qu'on va continuer
d'avancer au sénat là dessus parce
qu'elle a sur le fond une vraie utilité
mais l'utilité n'existe qu'à la mesure
des moyens qui sont données pour
exécuter ma peine
le débat sur sur la prison pour clore le
débat sur la prison faut quand même
remarquer que dans le projet annuel de
performance 2019 on a une baisse de 31 %
des subventions aux associations
culturelles et sportives
j'entendais madame la ministre à leur
dire qu'il fallait que la pression soit
utile quel est le problème principal en
prison segment les prisonniers les
détenus passent beaucoup trop de temps
en cellule et beaucoup trop peu en
activité comment comment vous avez rêvé
de ça parce qu'elle doit travailler le
député est ce qu'elles doivent
travailler parce que là aujourd'hui un
député nicolas dupont aignan qui
déposent une proposition qui veut faire
payer
un tarif quotidien aux détenus non ça
qui serait pris sur leurs salaires en
sano qu'un fou si une fonction qui donne
sur le salaire c'est sur les victimes
c'est totalement ça n'a aucun sens à
mesure l'enjeu de celui qui travaille en
maison d'arrêt et qui perçoit une
indemnité c'est d'indemniser les
victimes en premier avec nous sommes
dans une fonction régalienne de l'état
mais par contre il doit travailler pour
payer les victimes le sujet juste pour
répondre à monsieur bernalicis moi je
partage son analyse
aujourd'hui il ya trop peu d'activité
pour les détenus en détention quand on
parle d'activité je parle de formation
je parle de travail et dans les
établissements que nous allons
construire nous souhaitons aussi
désencombrer 2009
4 voir la news installé des ateliers
comment vous expliquer sa canne en main
au moins les choses il devance aux
associations culturelles et sportives
écoutez nous avons absolument pris en
compte cet élément est dès lors que nous
allons avoir les moyens de donner du
travail nous allons pouvoir
effectivement subventionner les actions
qui nous françois noël buffet un autre
sujet dans le domaine civil même le
ministre vous amorcez là à la fois la
dématérialisation des procédures vous
amorcez également la numérisation de ce
ministère dont il faut bien l'admettre
qui est encore à la préhistoire du
numérique
et ça c'est absolument nécessaire
l'enjeu pour nous est l'inquiétude c'est
comment on assure la défense de celui
qui est le plus faible et notamment dans
les procédures numériser tout le monde
n'a pas la disposition un dispositif
informatique c'est une chose mais y
compris d'ailleurs sur les moyens de
recours en créances automatisé qui sont
mis en place
il faut impérativement protéger les plus
faibles or il faut conserver avant un
autre l'accès au juge dans le texte je
ne le vois pas alors je pense que vous
avez mal lu monsieur cérétanes
évidemment nous allons vers la voie de
la numérisation du ministère vous dites
que le ministère est encore à la
préhistoire je ne voudrais pas que le
sénat lui soient restés au 20e siècle
nous nous sommes déjà dans le 21e siècle
et nous considérons que nous et nous
devons aller vers des procédures
numérisés mais aller vers des procédures
numérisé qui simplifieront la tâche des
magistrats simplifieront la tâche des
professions du droit ne signifie pas que
nous voulons éloigner le justiciable de
son juge loin de là nous voulons
évidemment dans chaque lieu où il y aura
un tribunal dans chaque tribunal
nous avons mis en place ce qu'on appelle
des sauges c'est à dire des services
d'accès unique du justiciable qui
accueille les justiciables qui les
aideront à remplir leurs procédures
numérisés
si elles le sont nous continuerons
évidemment accepté les procédures papier
bref nous sommes à la fois dans
l'exigence du 21e siècle et du 22e et en
même temps le contact réel avec le
besoin de proximité avec les
justiciables
je vous remercie cette précision mais
dans le texte nous le nous apporterons
les amendements nécessaires à la réalité
de cette protection de celui qui est le
qui est le plus faible puisqu'elle sort
que fait qu'elle garantit au maillet les
possibles de recours au juge quel que
soit l'état de la procédure dès lors
qu'il ya une difficulté majeure
il faut avoir accès aux joueurs leur
tour bus mais à certaines procédures qui
le progrès sur la numérisation là je ne
dis pas que rien n'a été fait
précédemment et le sénat est plutôt en
général assez en avance sur les choses
donc au contraire nous en voulons plus
parce que le ministère mais ce n'est pas
que de votre responsabilité mérite
d'aller beaucoup plus loin en matière
numérique
donc l'enjeu la volonté c'est d'aller
très très loin et très juste sur jean
vous avez raison c'est urgent et je
pense que la crédibilité de la réforme
que je porte
elle passera par la numérisation et nous
avons des moyens extrêmement important
enfin je sais donc les chiffres ça ne
veut rien dire mais quand même un demi
milliard est consacrée en resortir
peut-être des dossiers techniques
d'autres sujets vous
sur l'accès à la justice clairement on a
parlé du numérique il ya un autre aspect
notamment en matière civile
aujourd'hui il ya cinq modes pour saisir
le tribunal d'instance 5 modalités
différentes
il ya une tentative de simplification
dans ce texte qu'il ya un mode unique de
saisine du tribunal d'instance
c'est à dire de l'assignation par
rapport aux huissiers or un huissier
pour faire un acte de base si vous le
vrai dj vous même et qui le valide
une fois que vous lui présentez ces 75
euros minimum en moyenne on sera entre
100 et 120 euros pour quelque chose qui
a tardé pour quelque chose qui étaient
auparavant gratuits vous avez sans doute
me parler de l'aide juridictionnelle et
vous auriez raison de me parler de
l'aide juridictionnelle certaine
certainement oui bien sûr sauf que dans
plein dans plein de domaines vous
l'avais dit dans la première partie on
augmente l'obligation de représentation
dont acte en mieux que qui est un
conseil qui soit rendue obligatoire mais
le corollaire de ça c'est d'augmenter
drastiquement l'aide juridictionnelle et
de détendre son accès or je suppose que
les gens ne savent pas qui nous
regardent ce soir que avant qu'ils y
aient accès que l'aide juridictionnelle
pour être pris en charge à 100%
il faut gagner moins que le smig mois
que les chartistes plus coûteuse parce
que je ne partage pas l'avis de monsieur
le député d'abord parce que évidemment
vous savez notre jauge était à flers
dans l'orne et j'étais dans un tribunal
d'instance
les gens qui viennent là ils peuvent
déposer leurs requêtes d'ailleurs très
souvent ils arrivent avec des papiers et
par et divers et c'est la personne qui
est à l'accueil qui va faire le travail
de remise en forme et c'est donc si vous
voulez il n'y a pas d' assignation par
huissier et nous n'avons absolument pas
et nous n'avons absolument pas le besoin
de généraliser pour tous les contentieux
ce type d'assignation donc d'abord il
faut dire les choses telles qu'elles
sont ensuite bien sûr que nous voulons
retravailler sur l'aide juridictionnelle
nous n'avons pas prévu de dispositions
dans le texte que je porte parce que
c'est un travail extrêmement long que
j'ai engagée avec les avocats et je
souhaite pouvoir poursuivre avec lui
mais là ça va être demain qui va falloir
passer par ces modes qui vont couper le
sergent
c'est moi le travail que je fais avec
les avocats il trouvera sa traduction
il trouvera sa traduction dans la loi il
reste quelques minutes seulement
messieurs alors monsieur le député vous
vouliez parler des nominations dans la
justice vous avez dû faire tout de suite
monsieur le sénateur vous vouliez parler
d'un autre aspect important sur la
réforme constitutionnelle balizy et puis
le début c'est aussi un lien que la
réforme constitutionnelle c'est clair
qu'on on clame l'indépendance de la
justice et on a raison de le faire
toutes et tous partout où on va
sauf que dans la nomination des
procureurs
on a vu que il y avait une divergence
entre vous madame la ministre et le
président de la république à une étape à
la dernière étape
bon alors même que dans la réforme
constitutionnelle que vous portiez vous
expliquerez sillage aussi à ma part mais
si dans la réforme constitutionnelle que
vous portiez il y avait une modification
du conte c'est super de la magistrature
pour avoir un avis conforme
ça veut dire que dans le cas d'espèce
vous auriez était encore plus des dites
par le parlent par le président de la
république je ne crois pas à monsieur
députés juste d'un mot pour dire je ne
veux pas reprendre devant ceux qui nous
regardent le raisonnement que j'ai fait
tout à l'heure il va de soi que sur les
magistrats du parquet nous considérons
que le pouvoir de proposition que
détient le pouvoir exécutif fait partie
de notre histoire constitutionnelle
russe et non sur le nom parce que
maintenant quand même et non il n'y a
aucune cellule
il n'y a aucune suspicion sur le
magistrat puisque je voulais dit tout à
l'heure sur l'opportunité des poursuites
sur les décisions individuelles
il est totalement libre et indépendant
et lorsque vous parlez de
la suspicion pardonne moi je passais le
mot vous avez utilisé mais il n'est pas
du tout anormal que sur le poste de
procureur de paris qui est quand même le
poste de procureur le plus important au
centre de la sécurité publique des
attentes antiterroriste qu'il gère
actuellement il ne me semble absolument
pas normal que le premier ministre et le
président de la république engage avec
le garde des sceaux un dialogue pour
voir quelle est la personne qui reste
une minute elle est bien entendu mais
regardez ce que je disais tout à l'heure
que vous étiez favorable au maintien
entre de lien entre le procureur de la
république
enfin les désignations des procureurs la
république est également et le pouvoir
politique finalement donc dans la
réforme constitutionnelle donc dans la
réforme constitutionnelle que vous allez
porter
cela sera confirmé clairement nous
portons le texte nous portons exactement
le texte qui a déjà été adopté par le
sénat et qui vise donc à le donner
absolument à donner davantage de
pouvoirs d'autonomie aux magistrats du
parquet puisqu'ils seront nommés sur
avis conforme du conseil de la
magistrature et que le pouvoir
disciplinaire appartiendra au conseil
mais il faut quand même il faut que la
constitution'' attentionné le sortir de
la république sont aussi là pour
appliquer les choix et les orientations
massés ce que j'aimais dans la politique
pénale
c'est ce que j'aime bien sûr c'est tout
merci messieurs donc voilà on suivra le
débat donc demain à partir de 20 avant
goût un peu de la nature des échanges et
tu as ton du ton qui restera courtois
bien sûr fais mes courses soit verbe est
courtois au sénat donc elle a semblé
aussi une idée à l'assemblée aussi merci
à tous les deux vous céder la place
maintenant à oriane mancini à brigitte
boucher qui arrive dans la dernière
partie de l'émission avec nicole
belloubet
bonsoir à vous oriente brigitte
vous allez pouvoir continuer donc
d'interroger lors de cette audition
publique la ministre de la justice alors
qu'il ya des réactions à des internautes
du figaro qui attire notre attention sur
la situation des islamistes radicaux en
prison ou encore du malaise parmi le
personnel pénitentiaire ou bien sur les
bandes qui continuent de
se battre entre elles les rixes dans la
rue alors que la justice les connais
pourquoi ne sont ils pas présent ce sont
des sujets que vous allez aborder
organes oui on va commencer par parler
des violences conjugales mais de la main
ministre puisqu'une femme et tué tous
les trois jours sous les coups de son
compagnon de son ex compagne en 225
mille femmes ont subi des violences en
2016 ce week end l'est des
manifestations dans toute la france à
l'initiative de muriel robin et on
entendu ces femmes victimes d'hier la
justice n'est pas la hauteur de nos
souffrances
qu'est ce que vous leur dites alors je
leur dis d'abord que ce sont souvent des
drames que vivent ces femmes et donc
nous devons être à la hauteur et à
l'écouté de ce qu'elles vivent et nous
devons être en mesure absolument de leur
apporter des réponses
le gouvernement pour cela a pris un
certain nombre de décisions et que ma
collègue schiappa apporter je ne les
reprend pas ici j'observe également que
quand on dit la justice n'est pas à la
hauteur
cela vise la justice stricto sensu mais
parfois tout le processus d'écouté et de
solution face aux problèmes qu'elles
rencontrent donc sous le mot justice se
cristallisent des demandes souvent plus
large mais j'en assume complètement ma
part de responsabilité moi je pense
quatre choses en deux minutes
1 nous avons un dispositif pénal de
réponse qui me semblent relativement
satisfaisant qu'il me semble
satisfaisant mais deux nous devons
améliorer la situation pour aider les
femmes à porter les victimes à porter
plainte
pour cela nous allons mettre en place
une plateforme avec ministère de
l'intérieur de saisine en ligne par chat
d'abord et qui permettra ensuite
d'engager pour grande début novembre
début novembre 2018 oui oui elle est
prête d'engager absolument déjà ça
permettra évidemment d'engager une
procédure
nous allons également je crois que c'est
très important le
nine certes la justice va déployer un
guide pratique pour l'écouté
l'accompagnement des victimes qui sera
adressé aux magistrats et aux enquêteurs
ce sera à la fin de cette année nous
allons également développer la formation
de nos magistrats
ils ont touché une formation obligatoire
mais en formation continue il faut que
nous améliorions les choses donc un
aider les victimes à porter plainte ça
c'est un premier point
deuxième chose protéger les victimes
protéger les victimes et pendant tout le
temps où la plainte a été portée ils
font que soyons mesure de protéger les
victimes
on va développer le téléphone grave
danger qui est donnée à ces femmes par
décision du juge et qui leur permet par
un simple touche d'appeler les forces de
l'ordre si elles sont en difficulté nous
allons passer à plus de 1000 téléphonant
quelques en quelques temps nous allons
également je crois que c'est très
important
développez également les mesures
d'éloignement du conjoint violent avec
des interdictions de paraître mais nous
devons aussi accompagner les
associations qui assure l'hébergement
soit des victimes soient du conjoint
violent puisque il arrive parfois que le
conjoint violent ne puisse pas être
éloigné parce qu'il n'a pas de lieu où
aller et donc c'est que c'est souvent la
femme qui s'en va tout simplement parce
qu'il ya des inégalités aussi c'est ce
que je vous dis financièrement cela elle
veut pas c'est la raison pour laquelle
nous nous apercevons aujourd'hui qu' il
faut parfois trouver un hébergement aux
conjoints violents pour les nouvelles
pour l'éloigner à l'excellent qui ont
manifesté samedi notamment l'appel de
muriel robin il ya d'autres appellent
elles demandent l'éviction systématique
les absolument et bien ça nous pouvons
le faire nous demandons aux magistrats
de le faire lorsque évidemment les
conditions sont réunies
puis le troisième point porté plainte
protéger le troisième point qui me
semble également extrêmement important
c'est d'améliorer les délais puisque moi
j'ai entendu samedi des femmes qui
disaient j'ai déposé plainte il ya un an
et souvent extension est effectivement
lorsque analyse quand elles sont sans
suite ça veut dire qu'elles ont été
examinés et où elles ne sont pas
traitées alors le problème c'est
qu'elles n'ont pas de nouvelles en tout
cas et quand s'est classé sans suite
elle ne savent pas pourquoi donc il faut
que nous travaillions avec les
associations pour qu'elle soit en mesure
d'expliquer pourquoi s'est classée sans
suite il faut que nous travaillons en
amont sur le recueil des preuves car
c'est évidemment capital à partir du
moment où vous engager une action
justice il faut pouvoir
prouver des choses et donc évidemment le
recueil des preuves est important avec
le ministère de la santé nous allons
essayer de développer des expériences
qui se déroule dans certains hôpitaux où
les femmes peuvent venir et déposer des
preuves assure enfin qu'il est un
prélèvement de chose qui pourrait
ensuite servir de preuve si elle porte
plainte et fuit pas suffisamment de
moyens aussi
cent mille euros dead là où les
associations réclamaient ce week end je
disais oriane 25 millions est ce que le
gouvernement fait a cessé 0,007 % du
budget de la nation je ne veux pas me
prononcer là sur les cent mille euros
j'ai cru comprendre que ça correspondait
à une demande précise d'une association
qui souhaitait qu'ils souhaitaient le 30
nov 09 qui souhaitait pouvoir assurer
une meilleure réponse que les idées
consacré suffit 100 mille euros c'est
pas le budget global
par ailleurs moi je ne gère qu'une
petite partie du budget et je vais
augmenter ce budget de 25 à 30 millions
ce qui est tout de même importante sur
les violences sexuelles les plantes là
sont en hausse mais les condamnations
sont en baisse en dix ans le nombre de
condamnations pour viol a baissé de 40%
celles pour agression sexuelle de 20%
comment vous expliquer ce paradoxe bien
jeu c'est un peu ce que je viens de vous
dire c'est à dire que healy a souvent un
recueil de preuves qui est extrêmement
difficile et donc nous devons agir l'a10
une tendance mais militante que vous
avez peut-être trouve extrêmement se
dire mais pourquoi cette présomption
d'innocence parfois quand on a des
situations vraiment évidente alors je
pense que non ça me fait pas bon dire
parce que je comprends que face à la
souffrance on peut avoir des
raisonnements qui ne sont pas
nécessairement juridique je crois malgré
tout que nous devons respecter les
principes fondamentaux notre état de
droit
neuf victimes de viols sur dix ne porte
pas plainte comment vous vous expliquer
cela bien je vous dis je crois que
d'abord il ya le choc
ensuite il ya le fait que ce sont
souvent des violences intrafamiliales
qu'on ne veut pas dénoncer un agresseur
que l'on connaît il est ensuite la
complexité de la situation
il ya des femmes qui n'ont pas envie
d'aller
la gendarmerie d'aller voir un policier
et c'est la raison pour laquelle la
plate forme de plainte en ligne que nous
proposons nous pensons que ça peut être
un outil j'ai parfois entendu vous les
loyers la justice non pas du tout au
contraire c'est l'idée de dire que une
victime peut chatter c'est peut-être
moins difficile que de se retrouver
directement face à quelqu'un et après
elle va être recontactés par les séries
après lancera ses prix après deux ans
voilà innovant 24 oui absolument et 7
jours/7 et moi je redis encore que dans
dans ces questions-là de violences
sexistes ou sexuelles sexuelle en
l'occurrence ou conjugale la preuve est
important donc tous les éléments de
preuve et donc plus tôt on a le courage
de porter plainte
la justice peut agir à un mot puisque ce
week-end a été confirmée aux etats-unis
la nomination à la cour suprême du juge
bresse kavanaugh conservateur accusé
d'agressions sexuelles que pensez vous
de cette nomination et du signal
qu'elles envoient alors je crois que les
accusations qui étaient portées contre
lui datent d'il ya trente ans me
semble-t-il
je trouve que
la nomination de ce juge à la cour
suprême va complètement bouleverser les
équilibres de la cour suprême
quand on connaît l'importance de la cour
suprême aux états unis qui évidemment
sur les questions sociétales joue un
rôle clé nous allons maintenant nous
avons maintenant une cour qui sera
constituée majoritairement de
conservateurs les progressistes je crois
ne seront plus que quatre
et j'ai réalisé cinq conservateurs je
trouve que c'est vraiment une situation
très difficile pour moi ancien membre du
conseil constitutionnel de voir cette
évolution aux états unis
brigitte à votre sujet on parle de la
radicalisation en prison à la
radicalisation vous vous répondez par
des quartiers étanche est ce que vous ne
pensez pas que ça peut créer une sorte
de cellule dormante à l'intérieur même
des prisons alors je réponds si vous me
permettez par plusieurs choses je
réponde à bord
je répond d'abord par une évaluation
puisque nous n'avons pas toujours à
faire face aux mêmes types de personnes
vous avez des personnes qui sont très en
relais dans la radicalisation et
d'autres qui au contraire sont plus dans
la posture et donc nous avons nous avons
mis en place des quartiers d'évaluation
de la radicalisation cela dure quatre
mois ils sont prises en charge par des
psychologues des thérapeutes des imams
il ya toujours un point cultuelle qui
est important bref au terme de ces
quatre de ses seize semaines ces quatre
mois nous sommes en mesure d'évaluer
leur dangerosité
ce qui nous permet de les placer dans un
établissement pénitentiaire qui est
adapté à leur niveau de dangerosité
certain seront placés à l'isolément pour
les plus dangereux d'entre eux c'est par
exemple le cas de monsieur redoine faïd
qui est aujourd'hui à l'isen non
d'autres seront placés dans des
quartiers de prévention de la
radicalisation qui sont nous l'avons
garantit aux surveillants pénitentiaires
qui seront des quartiers et ange c'est à
dire qu'ils seront isolés du reste de la
détention
mais ça ne signifie pas que nous
n'essaierons pas de continuer à
travailler avec ces détenus pour les
réinsérer dans un processus non violent
et donc de déradicalisation et d'autres
encore pourront au terme d'un processus
pourront être répète magazine afin de
les laisser entre eux finalement est ce
que vous ne craignez pas qu'à la salle
si les uns et les autres sont raides
finalement pour retourner dans des du
terrorisme je ne pense pas parce que ils
ne sont pas laissés seuls entre eux il y
as je le dis dans ces quartiers qui
comprend qu'ils seront de petites unités
de moins de 30 personnes
il y a évidemment tout un travail
d'accompagnement pénitentiaire avec ces
personnes là est ce que nous essayons
également de ce que nous essayons de
faire c'est d'éviter le prosélytisme ils
ne sont pas ils sont dans un quartier
étanche mais dans une prison qui
accueillera d'autres types de détenus
donc nous avons essayé de pallier à la
fois l'inconvénient que l'on a pu
mesurer dans d'autres dispositifs où
tous les to les radicaliser sont
regroupés dans une seule unité
pénitentiaire
mais en même temps nous essayons
d'éviter le prosélytisme et je suis allé
il n'y a pas très longtemps à
condé-sur-sarthe voir un quartier
étanche et on voit bien que à la fois il
y a le prosélytisme n'est pas possible
par toutes sortes de dispositifs foyer
sans maintenance est pas un foyer
non je ne le crois pas je ne le crois
pas parce que je crois que le travail
qui est conduit avec eux évitent de
faire perdurer ce foyer là à condé sur
ça qu'il s'agit d'un quartier de prise
en charge la radicalisation c'est le
deuxième en france avec celui de lille
osc
aura d'autres qui vont absolument c'est
bien ce type là de deux quartiers que
nous souhaitons pouvoir développer avant
la fin du quinquennat les ouvriront oui
nous avons dit que nous aurions 1500
places de quartier étant il ya 450
radicaliser qui devrait sortir de prison
à la fin de l'année prochaine comment
l'état va-t-il gérer ces situations
encore une fois je pense que dans les
radicaliser qui est un mot valise et
pardonnez moi il faut juste distinguer
ce que l'on appelle les détenus
terroristes islamistes
et puis les gens qui sont des détenus de
droit commun et qui ont montré en
détention quelques signes de
radicalisation
j'en vois beaucoup vu passer
malheureusement l oeuvre ces derniers
mois en france c'est bien oui non mais
je ne dis pas qu'il n'ya pas de risque
je dis simplement que les uns ne sont
peut-être pas équivalents des autres dès
lors que ces personnes sortent six mois
ou pas d'abord je dois dire que en
détention nous avons des cellules de
renseignements qui fonctionne en
détention et qui nous permettent de
suivre leur activité de mesurer leur
évolution déjà six mois avant leur
sortie
le service de renseignement établissent
d'abord avertissent les services de
renseignement en dehors de la prison et
établissent des fiches qui permettront
de suivre ces détenus sont des fiches
excès pas un petit bout de papier
c'est vraiment des choses extrêmement
détaillées qui permettront de suivre les
détenus et dès qu'ils sortent évidemment
ils sont prises en charge par les
services de renseignement territoriaux
voir par le parquet national anti
terreur 5
vous savez c'est pas une situation
rassurante y compris pour la ministre
mais moi je pense que nous sommes dans
un état de droit que lorsqu'une pen est
accomplie elle est accomplie en qu'en
revanche il est de notre devoir de
mettre en place tous les saints tous les
éléments de surveillance de suivi qui
sont extrêmement resserré pour éviter
que ce type de personne ne soit un jour
tenté de passer à l'acte regarde on va
parler de redoine faïd un navet s'est
énervé exactement on a appris qu'il
avait entamé une grève de la faim pour
protester contre l'incarcération de sa
logeuse et la mise en examen des
personnes qui l'ont aidé pendant son
évasion
quelle est votre réaction ma réaction
c'est que redouane faid n'a pas
s'opposer au traitement judiciaire qui
est donnée aux personnes qui l'ont
hébergé ou qui l'ont aidé à s'évader
c'est tout même on marche sur la tête
donc je vois là j'entends ce matin que
l'administration pénitentiaire dans ce
cas ça c'est un détenu comme ça face à
redouane feuilles oui bah écoutez et
pose en soi déjà actuellement culte et
puisque c'est un condamné à une longue
peine
évidemment et que là les conditions sont
actuellement il est voilà il est dans un
état il est à vendin-le-vieil qui est
l'une des trois prisons les plus
sécurisées de france il est actuellement
placé à l'isolément
ce qui signifie que évidemment il ne se
déplace pas en dehors de sa cellule sans
être menotté et en étant très encadrée
actuellement je crois savoir qu'il n'a
pas de parloir donc il est vraiment dans
une situation très très surveillé voilà
il nous appartient évidemment de veiller
à sa santé donc là je pense que
l'établissement pénitentiaire n'y aussi
à ce qu'elle ne tente pas de s'échapper
à nouveau ça veut dire que la cape les
conditions de la chanson que vous venez
de décrire le sens qu'appeler à perdurer
alors là nous verrons comment est-ce que
les choses évoluent mais il est évident
que la manière dont il s'est évadé
récemment nous conduit à la surveillance
la plus exigeante
il s'est évadé par hélicoptère pour la
deuxième fois parce qu'il n'y a pas de
filet sur la cour d'honneur
il ya d'autres prisons en france qui
n'ont pas de filet est ce que cette
situation a changé depuis trois mois la
date où redoine faïd 7 à nouveau évadé
alors nous avons évidemment pris des
décisions d'une part la centrale de
réaux d'installer les filins anti
hélicoptère sur cette cour d'honneur et
nous avons demandé des analyses sur les
prisons où nous avons des systèmes
comparables pour voir dans quel délai
nous allons pouvoir installer ses fils
armés très clairement nous ne faisons
absolument
alors qu en fait il était
juste je le redis parce que j'ai déjà eu
l'occasion de le dire au départ
si l'administration pénitentiaire a
pensé qu'il n'était pas opportun
d'installer des filins sur les courts
d'honneur c'est pas par défaut de
surveillance parce qu'en principe un
détenu n'ait jamais dans la cour
d'honneur forcément il entre dans la
prison par la cour d'honneur et il en
sortira par la cour d'honneur mais il ne
circule pas dans la cour d'honneur et
donc on a pensé surtout dans celle de
réaux qui était extrêmement étroites
donc pas extrêmement mais qui étaient
étroites
on a pensé que ce n'était pas pertinent
c'était une erreur et les réparer a
parlé du malaise des agents
pénitentiaires des gardes des conditions
de travail difficiles et en même temps
des difficultés à recruter ce qu'il ne
faut pas revaloriser cette profession un
agent pénitentiaire au début de sa
carrière gagnent 1400 euros par mois oui
plus des primes parce qu'il est souvent
conduit à faire des heures
supplémentaires et donc cela accroît son
salaire oui vous avez raison il y a un
malaise parmi les surveillants
pénitentiaires les événements du mois de
janvier dernier l'ont montré mais nous
avons réagi par rapport à cela et nous
avons mises en place je n'ai pas le
temps sans doute si le détailler ici
mais nous avons mis en place des mesures
indemnitaire extrêmement importante qui
donc revalorise
le salaire des surveillants
pénitentiaires nous avons mise en place
des éléments pour plus de sécurité des
équipements qui sont en train d'arriver
dans les établissements pénitentiaires
je les détails pas ici dépasse menottes
qu'ils sont en train d'être s installer
les quartiers étanche dont je parlais
pour les détenus en voie de
radicalisation et puis nous voulons
revaloriser le rôle du surveillant dans
le travail quotidien qu'il effectue le
surveillant ce n'est pas seulement
quelqu'un qui porte des clés c'est
surtout quelqu'un qui observe les
détenus et qui est donc le mieux à même
de nous dire les difficultés que telle
ou telle rencontre où les évolutions
telles ou telles rencontres et donc nous
avons pris différentes dispositions qui
se traduiront d'ailleurs dans des textes
pour revaloriser stream ans était
reconduite demain vous échapperez à une
nouvelle grève des personnels à je fais
tout pour mais je le souhaite car je
pense que les mesures que nous avons
prises vont dans ce sens là et je
voudrais terminer juste en disant que
nous avons décidé de recruter 1000 sans
surveillants pénitentiaires
supplémentaires avec eux elle est
recrutée mais oui mais oui nous
réussissons les recruter nous avons eu
des concours et des promotions de 900
élèves là actuellement qui sont à
l'école nationale d'administration
pénitentiaire
ils sont tous là ils sont présents et
ils ont tous au niveau parce que
certains s'indignent de dix noms vous
savez la formation au bénévolat parce
qu'il ya des difficultés terribles pour
retrouver la formation à l'école
nationale d'administration pénitentiaire
est une formation d'un niveau quand même
élevé et ces gens là
les surveillants la suivre je pense
qu'une épave difficulté parlons à
présent de la réforme constitutionnelle
elle reviendra au mois de janvier au
parlement est là il y avait un coup
d'arrêt avec la sphère benalla est-ce
que vous pensez que cette fois elle
pourra être menée à son terme
alors je le souhaite vivement parce que
je cette révision le souhaitez mais vous
n'en êtes pas tout à fait sûr je ne
souhaite vue il faut l'accord des trois
cinquièmes et donc nous allons
travailler en ce sens moi ce que je
voudrais dire
c'est que ce débat a été interrompue
effectivement par la sphère benalla et
part à l'assemblée nationale
l'exploitation qui en a été donnée au
delà de la réalité de cet événement
c'est à dire que au fond cette révision
constitutionnelle heurtait un certain
nombre de députés ou de sénateurs quitté
d'ailleurs opposé à des dispositions qui
figurait dans la révision
constitutionnelle mais aussi à des
dispositions qui figurait dans les lois
adjacentes
les lois électorales bref il y a eu un
coup d'arrêt et ce coup d'arrêt ne nous
a pas permis de montrer que avant même
le débat qui s'était engagé à
l'assemblée nationale nous avions
travaillé avec la commission des lois de
l'assemblée nationale que le texte avait
déjà beaucoup bouger et qu'il allait
dans le sens d'un renforcement des
pouvoirs de contrôle et des voeux
position en tout cas sur une gérance
forcément des droits du parlement et est
bien une opposition a sûrement mal lu le
texte qui est entre ses mains avec un
petit peu plus d'autres jeux dessus je
ne vois pas ici de vin quand je présente
la réforme constitutionnelle
j'ai des certitudes c'est que 1 je veux
préserver les fondamentaux de la vème
république qui donne au gouvernement le
pouvoir de gouverner et au parlement le
pouvoir de contrôler et d'évaluer et
cela nous allons conforter ce sera
évident par exemple la loi de règlement
au printemps qui permettra au parlement
de voir comment le budget est exécuté ce
seront nous nous et on a rêvé que je
suis au moment où nous allions adopté un
amendement qui permettait d'organiser un
débat au parlement sur les opérations
extérieures
nous étions favorables à cela nous
sommes arrêtés juste devant le conseil
constitutionnel emmanuel macron n'a pas
parlé des sujets qui fâchent le sénat
par un mot sur la base du nombre de
parlementaires sur le droit d'amendement
sur le renouvellement du sénat
est ce que le chef de l'état est en
train de plier devant le sénat alors
d'abord emmanuel macron n'a pas abordé
tous les sujets dans la révision
constitutionnelle il n'a abordé qu'un
certain nombre d'entre eux sont en
baisse même si son ambition reste la
même argument et cela n'exclut pas
évidemment un dialogue qui va être
engagé
vous serez candidate aux municipales à
tolo ce nom la réponse est non
vous ne serez pas candidat je ne serai
pas candidate aux municipales à toulouse
voilà c'est qu'elle est pleinement
engagée dans mon travail ministériel
merci beaucoup madame la ministre de la
justice devraient être avec nous
aujourd'hui on se retrouvera donc très
vite j'imagine maintenant la semaine
prochaine c'est olivier faure le premier
secrétaire du parti socialiste qui sera
l'invitée d'auditions publiques bonsoir
à tous pour ce soir mais l'homme